Hallo ihr Lieben, heute machen wir den - lasst euch
das auf der Zunge zergehen - einen Apple Crumble
Cheesecake. Weil ich mir überlegt habe, ich hab' so
viele richtig leckere Apfelkuchenrezepte und
allgemein Rezepte mit Äpfeln, aber meine zwei aller
liebsten Rezepte, nämlich Cheesecake und
Apple Crumble, habe ich noch nicht vereint. Und ich
mach das jetzt einfach mal! :-) Und dafür machen wir
jetzt einen boden aus Butterkeksen & Butter. Die
Butterkekse dafür einfach fein mahlen. Das könnt ihr in der
Maschine machen und dann in eine Schüssel geben.
Falls ihr so eine Maschine nicht habt, einfach in
einen Gefrierbeutel tun und dann mit einem Nudelholz
richtig drauf kloppen. Und jetzt gebe ich da die
zerlassene Butter hinzu (das habe ich vorab in der
Mikrowelle zerlassen). Gut verrühren. Und ich gebe das
schon direkt in eine Springform mit 24 cm Durchmesser.
Ihr könnt auch einen Tortenring nehmen, ich mache das
immer nach Lust und Laune. Dann einfach
auf den Boden geben und schön platt andrücken.
So der Boden ist schon 'mal fertig, den geben
wir kurz an die Seite. Es ist übrigens kein "No-
Bake-Rezept", denn viele denken jetzt bestimmt: Nach
dem Boden kann nur ein No Bake-Rezept kommen. Aber den
könnt ihr tatsächlich auch backen. Für die
Cheesecakemasse nehmen wir uns jetzt Doppelrahm-
frischkäse. Das wird so typisch amerikanisch.
Da gebe ich dann direkt noch Zucker mit hinzu.
Habe ich euch gesagt, dass ich da noch Karamell zufüge?
Damit wir noch einen karamelligen Touch haben, weil
ich finde, das passt einfach richtig gut. Da nehme ich einfach meine Trilecesoße, das könnt ihr
nämlich auch benutzen, falls die daheim habt.
Oder ihr macht euch Karamell einfach selber.
Zur Cheesecakemasse geben wir dann noch Sahne,
ein bisschen Zimt und Speisestärke. Die Speisestärke
habe ich hinzu gesiebt, damit keine Klümpchen
darin enthalten sind und zu guter Letzt noch die
Eier dazu rühren. Wichtig ist, dass ihr allgemein
mit dem Teig sehr vorsichtig umgeht und
immer nur so in 10-Sekunden Intervallen
einrührt. Die Eier werde ich
immer einzeln einrühren. Immer nur so lange,
bis sich eins verbunden hat. Dann kommt das
nächste dazu. Und dann ist die Cheesecake-
masse fertig und kommt erst mal an die Seite.
Jetzt kümmere ich mich um die Streusel, die
sind nämlich super schnell zusammen geknetet.
Dafür habe ich hier zimmerwarme Butter, da gebe ich
dann noch braunen Zucker, Vanilleextrakt und Zimt
mit dazu. Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
findet ihr wie immer unten in der Infobox (Videobeschreibung).
Wenn ihr möchtet, schreibt mir doch jetzt einmal die
Kommentare, was euer liebstes Apfelrezept ist.
Die Streusel sind auch schon ready, also es
wirklich ein Blitzrezept. Das einzige wobei man
gleich warten muss ist die Backzeit und später
die Auskühltzeit, aber dazu verrate ich gleich
mehr. Ich schäle jetzt hier schon einmal meine
Äpfel und werde sie fein schneiden und dann wird
schon geschichtet. Auf den Butterkeks-Boden
kommt dann nämlich unsere Cheesecakemasse,
dann die Äpfel obendrauf und die Streusel.
Und dann kommt er auch schon in den Backofen.
So die Streusel sind auch schon fertig - das hat
keine zwei Minuten gedauert. Jetzt kümmern
wir uns um die Äpfel, die habe ich geschält und in
kleine Stückchen geschnitten. Und weil es ja eher
so in richtung Herbst/Winter geht, machen wir da
auch noch ein bisschen Zimt rein.
Zucker gebe ich jetzt nicht noch mal zusätzlich dazu.
Haben schon ein bisschen Zucker in der Cheesecake-
masse und in den Streuseln. In den Streuseln ist sogar
brauner Zucker, der karamellisiert noch
mal richtig schön. Und sobald ihr das dann erledigt habt,
einfach alles Schichten: auf die Butterkekse
kommt die Cheesecakemasse, dann die Äpfel und
die Streusel und dann wird das auch schon gebacken.
Hamza (singt): "1, 2, oder 3 ? Das war erstmal vorbei ... seht
ihr, wenn ihr richtig steht." Kiki (singt): " 1, 2 oder 3 - was
ist denn das für'n Geschrei?" Hamza "Ja, wie lange noch?"
Kiki:"Man könnte echt meinen, wie sind bei Starbucks."
Hamza: "Ja, das sieht auch heftig aus." Kiki: "Lecker, lecker.
Das ist ein ein Apple Crumble Cheesecake mit
Caramel." Hamza: "Ich weiß, ich hab das mitbekommen und schon Stories gemacht. Das riecht so genial!"
Kiki: "Ich habe die Ofenzeit gar nicht verraten! Das waren 160 Grad Ober-/Unterhitze
im vorgeheizten Backofen für eine
Stunde (60 Minuten Backzeit)." Hamza: "vorgeheizten!"
Kiki: "Ich komme nicht darauf klar." Hamza: " Darf ich es sagen? Sch** ist der gut!"
Kiki: "Das ist jetzt nicht gespielt oder so etwas. Ich habe richtig Gänsehaut.Jetzt probiere ich den das erste Mal.ich habe richtig Gänsehaut."
Hamza: "Der schmeckt richtig heftig!"
Kiki: "Ich nutz gern Philadelphia, da bin ich ganz ehrlich zu euch.
Der hat einfach diesen salzarmen Geschmack und
ist so cremig. Dann der Butterkeksboden
richtig crunchy, Äpfel, Streusel und
Karamell."
Macht diesen Traumkuchen nach und
hinterlasst unbedingt ein Like, wenn euch das
Rezept gefallen hat. Hamza: "Ein Herbst-Winter-Traum."
Ich verabschiede mich, wünsche euch
noch einen wunderschönen tag und bis zum nächsten Mal
aus Kikis Kitchen.